there's something magical about seeing
the arrow flying at the target
archer is difficult enough you know on
the ground
to be on the back of the horse and to
feel the wind in your face
it's a challenge and i like challenge
my name is lucas novotny and i'm a boyer
and a horseback archer
what i do here is kind of a history
that's
revived in a sort of modern fashion
i
don't necessarily like to brag but i'm
considered to be one of the top archers
i started making bows
just as a hobby
and then it kind of just drew me in you
wouldn't be interested in a bow unless
you wanted to shoot it i mean why would
you want to make a bow unless you know
you wanted to pull that string and let
the arrow fly right
to come up with a bow that's perfect
it's almost next to impossible i suppose
but that's where the challenge lies you
know that's like in horseback archer to
get a perfect score on the run is you
know that that's a feat that happens
once in a while
here we have a hungarian course it's
scored by degree of difficulty forward
being difficult
side being the easiest
and the back being the most difficult
and scored the highest
korean style is basically fairly simple
it's 150 meter track with five targets
spread 30 meters apart
the kabak is a turkish style
dating back to ancient times
it's a pole that's seven meters tall
that's what we use as a standard
at the top of it you have a target
i'm not per se the best archer there is
i don't know how it's possible how i've
managed to collect so many medals
maybe it's the saying of the the one man
with one eye is the kingdom on the blind
or something
you